le canada a beau être un pays de plus en
plus diversifiée les forces armées reste
encore une affaire d'hommes blancs ils
représentent 71% des membres de
l'organisation selon un nouveau rapport
et les autres se sentent parfois exclus
ou discriminé oui j'ai vu le racisme
robert falcon oil est un cri du manitoba
à goûter aux insultes dès le début de sa
carrière militaire il venait d'arriver
sur la base de valcartier moi je suis
joindra par exemple
au canada
et
on aime pas les
autochtones et surtout il ne savait pas
où se plaindre les personnes qui
marsolais
décennies plus tard le problème est loin
d'être réglé constate la ministre de la
défense que nous devons reconnaître que
la discrimination existe aussi en
interne en promet d'agir rapidement pour
mettre fin au harcèlement et pour rendre
le processus de recrutement et de
promotion au sein des forces plus
inclusive
en side
car depuis 20 ans plus de 40 rapports
ont été présentés au ministère et les
recommandations ont souvent été mises de
côté ou abandonner la raison pour
laquelle il n'y a pas eu vraiment de
progresser parce que les forces
canadiennes ont mis l'emphase sur les
comportements individuels au lieu de
prendre en considération les problèmes
structurels et culturels reste qu'il ya
quand même certains individus à
surveiller de près comme ces militaires
qui croient ou suprématisme blanc en
2020 un réserviste des forces armés
soupçonnés d'avoir flirté avec l'extrême
droite a foncé avec son camion dans
rideau hall la résidence officielle de
la gouverneure générale selon le rapport
l'adhésion à des groupes extrémistes est
en croissance et elle devient de plus en
plus clandestine on a de la misère à les
identifier
ils réinventent à tout bout de champ
c'est une grande préoccupation
ultime en ces manifestations de racisme
ne sont pas seulement néfaste pour les
militaires qui subissent les insultes
d'où la discrimination est lui aussi à
l'organisation elle-même qui peine à
attirer de nouvelles recrues depuis
plusieurs années ici laurence hart et
radio canada ottawa